[Applause]
this film that you have that you're
putting out there into the world is
about a very Infamous story
um The Boston Strangler but the angle
it's taking is so unique in the sense
that it seems like it's women having
women's backs yes I think it is
extraordinary firstly that the we all
know the story of The Boston Strangler
and these women were completely erased
from the narrative which is shocking
that was the most shocking part of the
story yeah they helped unveil the
connections the connections and the
warnings and what we what people were
supposed to be looking out for because
everyone was terrified yeah and they
warned the women of Boston that
something was amiss because none of the
men in the establishment were paying
attention to these killings because the
women's lives weren't valued in fact we
have a clip actually let me throw you to
that it's stunning film too it's so
beautiful
came to the house put it in the mail
slot
it's just me and the kids home
you think it was a deranged cop or some
deranged
I'm not exactly pleased about it either
way
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
and Gene Cole these real life
journalists who as you say were sort of
put in the back seat erased even though
they were the ones who I think were
raising you know the biggest flag but
they also coined the name The Boston
Strangler so they were the two that
named it they were the two that linked
the killings you know and and actually
in the story of The Boston Strangler
they've been completely taken out Kira
you know I heard a story about you that
you yourself you know had a moment where
you had to really deal with as a woman
things coming at you in a way that was
really difficult to handle and navigate
yeah you share that yeah I mean I think
in my early 20s I became very famous and
that was a lot to take on I think it's a
lot to take on when you're a teen a kid
who doesn't really isn't really aware of
what you look like and isn't really a
way I was very tomboyish you know and
I'm playing these roles that are not
tomboyish they're they're gorgeous
they're the lustered after kind of
creatures in the films but what you do
and you know that that's make-believe
but actually you're put in a public
sphere where suddenly that's what's
being projected onto you so yeah I had I
had a breakdown at about 22 so I got a
pts I was I was diagnosed with PTSD you
know so it's just being a woman in the
public sphere how do we do that how are
we meant to you know navigate that space
where where there's not naturally space
for us and we have to fight for it and
you so you watch this film and you watch
this struggle that they have their
working mothers to try and be these
amazing journalists but also to raise a
family and also to have a great
relationship and you know something the
ball gets dropped somewhere and I think
so me reading the script and I think for
a lot of women who've seen this film
they found it a very cathartic
experience
um and so kind of to to be able to have
a story where you can explore that as
well is a very cathartic with a theme
party it is in the same circumstance
yeah because we were both you know
Finding ourselves working mothers of two
young children playing working mothers
of children that's right trying to
balance you know all those roles yeah
and we kept challenging how are you
today yeah tired yeah he's doing this
well nobody no it's lovely to have an
ally when you go to work and you're like
so I had a great one and I normally
pre-children would have done so much
research and I would have learned to
touch type because touch typing is
important if you're playing a journalist
at that era and I'm suddenly doing the
scenes where I'm meant to be typing I'm
like I have no idea how to I type I look
at her I'm like I can't touch like and
she was like of course you can't you
have two children pretend I'm sorry yeah
that's what we need yes now these two
women that you're portraying are real
life so what is one thing Carrie that
like because if they've been forgotten
and thanks to you guys and this film
they are absolutely the opposite they
are being brought out into light and
appreciated for their work what is one
thing about you know the real life hero
that you portray that we should know
well what I love about Gene's story is
she was headed for nursing school she
needed one more chemistry credit and she
was working at a pinkham's drugstore and
a young girl Francis McGrath disappeared
from the town and so all the all the
journalists were at the pinkhams using
the public telephone and she joked with
Bob Court hey you got a job for me and
he called her in that fall
um when she would have been going you
know to nursing school and she had uh
she she got a job as a copy boy and so
she never had an education in journalism
she worked her way up to become an
award-winning investigative journalist
and so I just love the story of her you
know making her way in that
male-dominated sphere from the bottom up
there was one point she was making 30 a
week and Child Care was 25 a week and
she and all the men in the office went
in the office with her to advocate for a
raise and it just goes the importance of
having analyze not just women which of
course we need but we need the men too
and Kira for your amazing woman yeah you
know yeah
um
well I think Loretta McLaughlin and she
became an award-winning medical
journalist and she was one of the people
at the Forefront of covering the AIDS
crisis in Boston yes well thanks to you
guys we now have that historical
evidence right out here in the present
day because you can go see the Boston
Strangler which you can watch today it
premieres on Hulu I love you guys so
much thank you so much for coming here
today
thank you
[Music]